how is like the reception of the album
been in the small amount of time that
it's been out
honestly man it's been really
crazy i was uh surprised because i
honestly i'm like
i didn't know how this was going to go i
was kind of nervous to put this out
because i never put the album out or i
never really did something like this
where i felt so exposed and i was like
mad um vulnerable vulnerable
you know so
it was giving me anxiety to put it out
because i'm like damn i just don't know
how it's going to be perceived because i
didn't go in here with no intentions to
make bangers or
a single or anything like i just went
over i just want to in the studio invent
it
you know so
i didn't know how they was going to
perceive it and so when it dropped and
saw i saw i didn't see the responses
until so the album dropped monday right
this was nuts album dropped monday
i didn't see the responses until
thursday because my phone had got [ __ ]
up oh wow right so i couldn't
swipe up oh wow i don't see the screen
or anything
so
um i finally go to apple
and i get it fixed and um and dude it's
like yo uh you loot
i was like yeah he's like yo your
album's fire it's like yo i appreciate
it i'm glad you [ __ ] with it because i
can't see anything yeah he's like oh bet
like let's get you squared away they did
and that's when i saw like all the
responses and everybody
really [ __ ] with the album i thought
that [ __ ] was fine
i think when you go in and you purposely
try to make a single or a banger it
never works right
i didn't even i didn't even i wasn't
even thinking like that though i just
literally went to the studio and was
just venting and [ __ ] yeah that's the
[ __ ] that cuts through man that's what
should people want to hear at the end of
the day
like you said earlier like
when you make a body of work you want
people to listen to the whole body of
work you don't want to be an artist like
i always tell everybody there's
longevity in being an artist who puts
out bodies of work and that depends on
hit records you know what i'm saying
nothing cause you could do the hard like
like get that hard ticket money get the
[ __ ] get that following who will buy
all your merch or support whatever you
do like and the way you're gonna do that
is just by being true to yourself bro
because that's that's what people relate
to no for sure